PROFESSOR: OK.
So what I'm going
to try to do now
is set up again
this equation and do
the analog of what
we're doing there
and try to determine this
function fk in some nice way.
All right.
So let's think of this equation.
I want to do it in pieces.
So psi of r is going to
be equal to some formula.
And then it has to be equal
to this right hand side.
Let's write the e to the ikz
the way we've done it before.
It's up there.
So I'll write it here.
Square root of 4 pi
over k square, sum of l
equals 0 to infinity,
square root of 2l plus 1, i
to the l yl 0 1 over 2 i e
to the ikr minus l pi over 2
over r minus e the minus
ikr minus l pi over 2.
Wow.
It's tiring this r.
Plus f of k of theta
e to the ikr over r.
OK.
So what do we have here?
We've written the right
hand side of this equation.
I copied it.
I have not done anything except
taking r much greater than a.
Because otherwise in the
plane wave into the ikz,
I could not have expanded
the Bessel functions
unless I took r greater than a.
But that's good, because
we now have our waves.
OK.
We have our waves there.
Now, look at this
right hand side.
Where is the incoming wave
in this right hand side?
The incoming wave is here.
That's the only term
that is incoming,
because this is
an outgoing wave,
and this is an outgoing wave.
So if I want to write
the left hand side,
the incoming wave of
the left hand side
has to be equal to this wave.
And of course, the outgoing
wave of the left hand side
will also have to be equal
to whatever is outgoing here,
but the incoming must be this.
So I'm going to write
this left hand side
and already use this and put
4 pi over k square sum of l
equals 0 to infinity 2l
plus 1 i to the l y l
0 1 over 2 pi, big parentheses,
and one outgoing wave
and one incoming wave minus
ikr minus l pi over 2 over r.
And here, I don't
know what to put,
but I've put already
there on the left hand
side of this
equation for psi of r
for the full solution, a wave
that matches the right hand
side, because it has
the same incoming wave.
And now, I'm going to use
some physical intuition
to guess what we'll have
to put on this part.
This is the step that requires
a little imagination, not too
much, because we already
did something similar here.
So what's happening
here and here is
intuition I think you should
keep after weeks of this course
when it's all forgotten,
there's some intuition
that you should keep.
And it's about this scattering
happening for each partial wave
independent.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: 2i.
PROFESSOR: 2i, yes.
No, 2 pi there.
Yes.
Thank you.
So here it is.
This is a solution, and we've
got the intuition already.
I will justify this later,
of course, very precisely.
But I think that
this one you need
to have a little bit
of an intuition of what
you should do.
And first, we said
each l works separately
to create a solution of
the Schrodinger equation.
That's superposition,
and it's [INAUDIBLE]..
Each l is working separately.
Each l is like a
scattering problem.
Each l has a wave that comes
in and a wave that comes out,
because these things, j and n,
have waves, and they have an
in and out.
So these have some in
wave and some out wave.
And if each wave
works separately,
it has an in wave and then out
wave, in a scattering problem,
these waves must have
the same amplitude,
because otherwise they wouldn't
have the same probability
current, and probability
would get stuck.
So this must be an outgoing
wave having this same amplitude
as this wave.
And by the argument
we have here,
it just differs by a phase.
So we'll put here e to the ikr
minus l pi over 2 plus 2i delta
l over r.
So that this wave, spherical
wave, that it's outgoing,
it has the same
amplitude as this one,
and cannot be the same.
The only difference
can be a phase shift,
and that's the phase shift.
So your picture is scattering
in three dimensions.
Looks like, OK, you
threw in a plane wave
and out came a
spherical wave out.
The other picture that is more
consistent with the way you
solve it is that you have an
infinite set of partial waves
for different l's, each
one scattering, the l
equals 0, the equal 1,
the l equal 2, all of them
scattering.
So this corresponds
to an [? ansatz ?]
in terms of phase
shifts, and now you
can say you've
parameterized your ignorance
in a physical way.
You've discovered that all that
characterizes the scattering
is, as it was in one
dimension, a phase shift.
In one dimension, there
was a single phase shift,
because you didn't have
all these general solutions
that you had in
three dimensions.
Your energy eigenstates
were momentum eigenstates
there were
non-degenerate really.
There was just a couple of
momentum eigenstates, wave in
and waves out.
Here is infinitely degenerate.
There's spherical stuff.
So there's a phase shift
for each value of l.
So we've parameterized the
physics of the scattering
problem in terms of phase
shift, and now, it's
interesting to try to figure
out what is this quantity
after all in terms
of the phase shifts.
It's already here.
We just have to solve it.
So from this equation, I now
can say that this term cancels
with this term, and now,
I can solve for this term
f of theta e to the ikr by
collecting these other two
terms together.
And therefore, fk of theta e
to the ikr over r is equal,
and it's exactly the same thing
I did here, cancel here, pass,
and the mathematics is going
to be completely analogous,
except that they have to
carry all that sum there.
No big deal.
So what is it?
Square root of 4 pi
over k, sum from l
equals 0 to infinity, 2l
plus 1, i to the l y l0.
1 over 2i.
OK, 1 over 2i.
OK, I'll do it this way.
e to the 2i delta l minus 1 e
to the ikr e to the minus il pi
over 2.
I think I got everything there.
I put the first term
on the right hand side,
I moved it to the
left hand side.
The coefficient
was all the same.
This was the coefficient they
both had the same coefficient.
Then I just have to subtract
these two exponentials over r.
So I did forget the r.
So I just subtract
the two exponentials.
Both exponentials have the e
to the ikr minus l pi over 2.
And the difference is that the
first exponential on the top
has the extra e to the
2i delta l minus 1,
and the other one doesn't.
So what do we get here?
This part is e to the
i delta sine delta,
and this part is e to
the minus i pi over 2
to the power l, which
is minus i to the l,
and i to the l times minus i
to the l is happily just 1.
i times minus i is 1,
and 1 to the l is 1.
So this term and
this term cancel.
So finally, and I can
cancel happily they
r dependence is all the same.
I can cancel this r
dependence, this r dependence.
And finally, we've
got fk of theta
equals square root of
4 pi over k sum from l
equals 0 to infinity square
root 2l plus 1 y L0 of theta e
to the i delta l sine delta l.
So that said, that's
our formula for fk
in terms of the phase shift.
So what have we achieved?
We want f of k, because that
gives us the cross section.
What we have figured out is
that the calculation of fk
really requires knowing
the phase shift.
And the phase shifts are defined
by that formula over there,
where we have estimated
how one wave is connected
to the other one, the
incoming and the outgoing
for a given fixed f, for a
given partial wave, how they're
offset by this phase shift.